through them here bezzie yours Bob's not
odds the bigger scorers but a ballot
today I was looking at these earlier and
I was really surprised busy is in the
Oxford English Dictionary no this is the
grand-am of dictionaries that goes back
to 1845 and even or not people were
talking about bizzy's even then so we
all like to think of these as being such
as you know slightly trashy new words
that shouldn't be allowed in but in fact
a lot of them have been around before
oMG for example it's been around since
1917 so you might go and write very
surprised indeed and we've got a few
more we can look at here as well
ridiculous banks goes back to the Romans
has yeah not as far as I know although
you might be surprised yeah I mean I
have my own bugbears here as well like
anyone else and I know there will be a
lot of people saying this is ridiculous
this is English dumbing down but you
have to remember people have said this
about English for centuries Shakespeare
got a really hard time because of all
the new words that he came up with and
the other thing that we have to remember
of course is English has to move on
otherwise like Latin it will just stand
still and you know it won't be a living
language anymore so there will be things
that none of us like I appreciate that
but but on the whole we have to move
with it and that is a perfect example
how we're moving with the time we've
been busy here on Sky News tonight don't
any of you is thinking that we don't
actually do anything but we're not at
all eggs see there our production team
is very busy playing a game of Scrabble
they've been trying out some of the new
words see the upload that we use more
than one set of letters in this how easy
in practice is it to use these words in
a game and do we need to redo the way
that the Scrabble board set up because
some of these letters have slightly
perhaps outdated scores and sometimes
it's not enough of them no that's very
true I think shizzle is on the list for
example in this you know there's one Zed
in the settle you could use a blank tile
obviously I'm actually interested
interestingly I spoke to Martin I'm and
he said he's a Scrabble world champion
and he said his view was I hate gloss
I'd hate to put it on the table but if
it won it you know it would be great but
his highest scoring word was conquest
which is a lovely word that's called in
some like three hundred and forty points
and so I think that you know I'm not
sure how much this is going to affect
people who have their own house rules
who will play the game as they always
have and I think
house rule to have and I would always
apply this to countdown as well is if
you're going to put down an obscure word
make sure you know what it means what
some of the others we can look at I
think yeah we know what they mean but on
the other hand that emerging 14 letters
for that I mean this is again a sign of
the times isn't it a movement technology
and things like we are yes and of course
that's affecting you know affecting the
way that we speak and other people are
quite scared of text speak
understandably but just to reminder we
were scared of the postcard we was
gather the telegram for the same reason
that actually it was going to bring
English write down and we were going to
just end up cutting up words and not
understanding each other and sometimes
those shortest words can be the bigger
school isn't that nice travel absolutely
and there is an argument that something
like will emerge you for example is easy
to remember or newbs then you know then
Kony is which is another Scrabble word
meaning I think the poisonous part of
hemlock so you could argue that actually
some of these might be a bit more
transparent than that than some of the
other ones in there absolutely
fascinating so that I think we've got
probably time now to go off and play get
do plays let's well I do although I get
mixed up with what's allowed in the can
tundish me what's allowed in this one
but I'll give you again definitely
brilliant